[Musica]
[Applauso]
buonasera buonasera ci siete stanchi
avete fame siamo fuori tempo massimo lo
so io parto subito perché 18 minuti non
sono pochi quando mi hanno chiamato
neanche invitato più alte ed io ho
pensato cazzo quello di steve jobs e ho
pensato quindi se bella dire parolacce
che aveva subito una brutta figura
e così siamo partiti e allora ho detto
cosa vado a fare la cosa posso
raccontare questo stato che questo è
l'argomento possa raccontare la mia
storia la storia di un cosentino che ha
vissuto la mia no ma da quattro anni
staminali insomma uno che siete pre
parecchio da fare che se n'è andato via
ci volte però ho pensato ai periodo in
cui sono abbastanza in conflitto perché
ma ecco perché non è vero abbiamo messo
abbastanza smisurato e lo stesso ero che
poi 50 vari dischi che ci possa stare su
immagini che ci porta a postare in
continuazione infatti i nostri sui
social art e signora
ora mi sto scappando da questo brutto mi
rispetta i miei colleghi e ho pensato
pandev ad urlare appunto la vittoria
e invece no io vorrei cogliere
l'occasione di stare su questo palco
molto molto importante per raccontarvi
un'altra storia che non è la mia è una
storia è la storia di un ragazzo che
nasce cresce e si evolve e diventa un
artista allarme sappiamo dove ale
[Musica]
ragazzi capisco che un teatro ma non di
addormentate ho bisogno della vostra
attenzione
saltiamo corea le gravissime
allora la storia da raccontare è
totalmente vero ok è bene alla parte per
cui fuggire
quindi voi dovrete concedermi 2 bugie
che risvegliano forse alla fine forse
faccio lo scarta all'uso propria si dice
sulla presenza bello evitare termini
cosentini per più format internazionale
non facciamo sempre con te quindi non
più guardare non mi sorridente quanto
dico qualcosa di così
guardate che fundation non voglio fare
perché più figure per quelle bugie è un
congiuntivo sbagliato perché sono
abbastanza emozionato quindi concedere
che alcuni congiuntivo sbagliato a
mandare la riforma diretti che hanno
chiamata chiave perché non sbagliare i
congiuntivi rapper e poi non c'era
perché lo sbaglio in quel motivo io sono
l'unico lo è perché non sbaglia i
congiuntivi e mi ritrovo che in
televisione ma bando alle ciance come
direbbe qualcuno di importante
la storia di kevin è anche un po la
storia della cultura che mi ha permesso
di trasformare la passione in
professione alla cultura per cui vivo il
grande amore della mia vita che è la
cultura hip hop sappiamo se li può
cos'è l'ipo l'orologio di una più
generale a chi ha detto un movimento
culturale non è proprio possibile che la
sua amministrazione
abete ha già definita una controcultura
è una cultura è un movimento culturale
che nasce alla fine degli anni 70 dei
ghetti newyorkesi sappiamo tutti cos'è
un ghetto ai tempi new york l'america
viveva la fine quasi non è vero però di
una situazione razziale abbastanza
particolare in cui i bianchi si
sentivano superiori a tutte le altre
razze e faccio una piccola digressione
continuamente io mi trovo spesso
raccontare la storia dell'hip hop fino a
qualche mese fa e ho davvero contento di
dire ora non ci sono più questi problemi
infatti abbiamo un presidente americano
altro americano che combatte il razzismo
sono due mesi che invece mi ritrovo a
dire purtroppo ora c'è un deficiente che
è ricoperta l'america che sta cercando
di riportare tutto diversa
a quei tempi ce l'ho ma situazione
razziale abbastanza particolare quindi
tutte le minoranze etniche venivano che
si sa che cos'è la tichetti erano questi
quartieri in cui le minoranze etniche
vivevano all'interno di questi palazzoni
di cemento dove non c'era niente
praticamente non c'era istruzione non
c'era voglia di crescere
non c'è la sanità non c'è la membrana
giornalismo ad esprimere tutto
integrando che si viveva coi denti in
quei posti
allora che succede all'interno di questa
situazione così assurda nasce e cresce
la nostra storia lippi perchè perchè
c'erano le ghette sappiamo questa sono
né che cosa sono le che nelle mani che
mi aiuta la trama animativo informandosi
st luppi nelle bande
vabbè allora ve lo dico io erano dei
gruppi di persone che spesso si
contraddistinguevano con dei colori e si
facevano la guerra fra di loro per
contendersi un iter di un territorio per
contendersi l'angolo dove spacciare per
contendersi i campetti da basket
cioè si facevano la guerra per niente
perché perché erano abbandonati a se
stessi
se tu la sono l'unità senza istruzione
senza spiragli di crescita senza
spiragli di produzione si scatena subito
sono la violenza però a mente qualcosa
di incredibile avvenga un miracolo
uno dei primi a perché ci può subito che
non hanno portato
foto nel video e niente così vediamo
problemi dovete ascoltare solo la mia
storia
se vi annoiate mi dispiace per voi
quindi non cercate immagini e pero
dovrete immaginarvi questo ragazzone
enorme di due metri grosso che gli amici
questo pezzo del nostro ministero a
chiamarlo ercole e lui si ribattezza col
nome di kool herc ok
cosa fece questo pool e questo perche e
un grande prendeva dei posti è
organizzata dei party organizzato delle
feste
ok e in queste feste erano qualcosa di
speciale uno per che prendevano i
ragazzi del ghetto è cosa nostra
distingueva ragazzi del ghetto che erano
pochi soldi quindi non potevano
permettersi di andare alle serate per la
disco dance di quegli anni della pta che
è quindi lui faceva le feste per il
ghetto rubava l'elettricità dei lampioni
perché non avevano un gruppo elettrogeno
e se qualcuno sa cos'è il gruppo
elettrogeno ora alzi la mano
diciamocelo è bravissimo
poi lo conosco tutti i suoi rivali
allora organizzato da queste feste che
prima di passare al cosa succedeva in
queste feste per che succedeva davvero
devo farvi un'anticipazione dimmi cos'è
un po più realtà a parte un movimento
culturale per chi non lo sa
dovete immaginare una macchina che si
muove su quattro ruote
ok una tv sono potete intervenire se non
siete d'accordo
qualcuno ha detto 5 per decenni di bot
va bene che partiamo dopo sono quattro
ruote una di queste vuote e quello che
faccio io
ma non si calerà il re del freestyle di
perdere ok poi c'è un'altra quota che il
writing sapete cos'è il writing è l'arte
di fare i graffiti questo tecnica
graffito fino a poco tempo fa era
rimasto un po male tra gli addetti ai
lavori ormai sta tutto canato quindi
possiamo salvo poi che cosa c'era cosa
c'è ancora la previdenza
sapete cos'è 13 s
io sono schianto precari e poi rischiare
di rompere questo prezioso microfono
preparato con cui mi si è tolta disagio
perché sono abituato ad altri microfoni
e poi c'è l'altra disciplina che il dj
cioè la parte di fare il dj
penso che tutti sappiano questo dice
perché tutti siamo stati una festa di 18
anni a un battesimo dice sento ormai c'è
bisogno che vi spiego cos'è licei mentre
quella di 100 anziani perché dice pure l
cellule erano e dj e che gli dice gul ed
allora cosa si è inventato i tempi prima
dell'hip hop prima del reggae prima di
questi movimenti culturali estremamente
forti non celi genoa c'erano le console
allora kool herc ha pensato prendo o
giradischi el'aumento qua un altro giro
dischi è l'aumento qua al centro metteva
lambisce la torre
ho anche conosciuto come hicks che aveva
questa all'evento dove c'è più spostati
questa ragazza si chiama fare spostare
il fallo era sinistra si pente il disco
di sinistra seppur esposti a destra si
sente del disco di destra prendevano i
rischi uguali ok come poteva essere un
classico di janis ma sappiamo tutti i
miei genitori che ha perciò no
anche io che potrebbe scagliarsi meno
male di me e io che sono dell'utile in
faccia
c'entra chi lo fa va bene non mi fate
dire che se cosentino grazie prendeva da
questi dischi uguali e non mangiava
tutto il pezzo ma che interessava la
parte melodica o la parte di assoli di
altri strumenti prende da solo
la batteria e il basso quindi era già
perché perché quelli sono quel suono mi
ricordava di più il suono metropolitana
del ghetto ok beni che succedeva che lui
rendere il disco che faceva alcuni già
annuncia poi una denuncia poi potrei
andare avanti anche per due tre giorni
per per tormentare avere poi al meglio
che resti qui a fare questa cosa che si
chiama cantin
e questa arte si chiamava breakbeat ok e
lui faceva questa cosa con i dischi e la
gente andava ai suoi blog parti ma
queste feste e ballava e si divertiva
qual era il miracolo il miracolo vero
che l'ha eletto andavano tutti i
componenti delle gag diverse quindi le
gag dei costumi canto degli italiani
dei sudamericani ok e quindi
teoricamente doveva succedere una
carneficina dovevano scannarsi perché
abbiamo già capito prima qual era il
tasso di violenza è in salita del ghetto
era altissimo
avete visto che succede però dalla
nostra assoluta che è cool er e poi
applicato al papa per poi mila master
flash dei ragionieri coloro che hanno
inventato di un po decretato che quei
pazzi quelle feste erano una zona franca
bisogna fare in casa con tutti insieme
era una zona franca cioè andavano di e
si divertiva ok dove vanno a fare festa
dovevano divertirsi
altra cosa che succede pallini che
successe il nome al nostro protagonista
entra dalla festa della nostra storia
che ci ha detto il suo nome
bravissimo attenti non mi ricordavo si
chiama kevin e che lei cantava ii e
vedeva che alcuni prete mano il
microfono e iniziavano a preparare ok
poi non solo lì in poi decretato queste
creano l'estensione franche ma inizio a
combattere la violenza con altri modi
perché ragazzi più grandi di teramo in
casa il caso di per cassina coltellate
rumene di perdere il fratello di
prendere il fucino e quindi iniziarono
ad inventarsi altre cose ora ci
spostiamo un po dai blog parti anche a
un altro fenomeno che si chiamano i
negozi sappiamo
roger che si mettevano 12 contro 12 ok e
si insulta invece di aver coltellate si
cimentarono questi nuovi modi no e si
buttava quindi le mamme più caro prezzo
l
non vi dico proprio come si ripete in
francia sì mi chiamano a male parole
ok si insulta finché il cerchio si
restringe matera con uno contro uno
ok uno contro uno e finché un giorno
arrivò qualcuno che era l'inter fratelli
tod's e iniziò una contro un ad
insultare in rima all'avversario e tutti
dissero madonna ma questo è un genio ma
che cosa che bob a questo insulti arriva
questo è fortissimo ok quindi non sente
la mano chiusi insultarono il clima e il
tonico e proprio alterati da cristalli
ok sapete cosa ti stai artista e
nell'arte di improvvisa lei prima io
devo tantissimo a trissino signore le
scritte andare ancora meglio per capire
che finivano queste cose non è così
l'ignoranza non il ma la soddisfazione
la soddisfazione di chi ci vuole
comunque
io la mia testa perché per dirla con dal
un esempio di cos'è un posto tra le
signore qui presente che una figurante
capitata questa cosa di stato è
impressionante di improvvisare le rime
sul momento io devo tantissimo
acquistare perché sono diventato un
writer e ho iniziato a fare il letto
proprio grazie al freestyle
se volete che ne faccio sentire un po
per farvi capire per far cadere
ok roma l'edizione che ha così non
battete le mani che giuro che sa andare
al tempo ascoltate da ragazzino faccia
quello allora sono finito sul palco per
senza sotterfugi quello che lega si
chiamava vigilucci adesso potete
spiegarmi costei micro il resto per
l'egitto fin altro scopo
parlo di quello che sono ernesto berra
ma dove folle me l'ha insegnato sul
palco steve jobs che presentare
[Applauso]
[Musica]
anche utilizzare proprio a far
acquistare e diventa molto forte nel
freestyle e inizia a raccontare le
storie dei membri della sua più cioè dei
suoi amici perché qualcuno ha iniziato a
breccare a ok mentre cool er e che
faceva la doccia
ciao ciao il brad pitt qualcuno che era
una stanza prestante fisicamente
iniziano a fare la break dance sui black
bird erano suoi amici e poi successe
questa cosa successe questa cosa
all'interno dell'i pod che una delle
cose più belle
secondo me e affascinanti di questa
struttura che la di cambio del nome i
rider cosa facevano
prendendo spunto da mostri sale della
cultura altro americana come poteva
essere mohame tadini che in passato si
chiamava cassius clay ok lui
ribattezzatisi con nome di mohamed ali
rinunciava al nome la schiavo allora
questa facendoti rai c'erano quelli che
parlano in poco rinunciavano al nome da
schiavo ok come io arrivato un certo
punto non ho cambiato il mio nome da
mirko in chiave loro prenderà il loro
nome lo cambiavano perché il nome che
gli avevano dato il nome di battesimo
era il nome con cui il ghetto poteva
riconoscerli allora la mettevano questo
nome
lo cambiarono si ribattezza vano con un
altro uomini scomponevano le lettere del
nome quindi nel mio caso vi faccio un
esempio la cabala inaugurale lo
trasforma marino
piccolo e andavano con le bombolette
adatta al capo sud riccione e sulle luci
e del ghetto proprio per dare colore al
ghetto e questa cosa del nome importante
anche perché tutto quello di cui vi sto
parlando
no nonostante qualcuno lo neghi ha
portato una grossissima rivoluzione
culturale che negli ultimi 40 anni
perché la musica pop è stata cambiata
totalmente dalla musica rap le batterie
della musica pop che sentite adesso da
pian di un se sono le batterie che sono
state progettate dalla dall'arte del
campionamento che l'arte di fare la
mosca retta ok non c'è tanta che non sia
stata influenzata dalla break dance
non c'è arte figurativa che non sia
stata influenzata da pratiche tragica da
doni alla street art che una delle forme
di all the date più importanti al
momento che è poi la del decennio numero
tipo proprio perché ha vinto quando mi
annoiava ribaldeschi cerioni j dal
battesimo alla riunione di oppure non
sono molto esperto di religioni però
fino al matrimonio fosse funerali no ma
in america co che ce lo dice reali
quindi qual era la forza di questa cosa
chiamata il pop che una rivoluzione
culturale incredibile totalmente al
venuta alla budget zero budget zero
qui si sta parlando di lasciare una
città per andare ma che io ho visto
soltanto una storia che un po una meta
pro ok io l'ho questo tagliare ma
purtroppo mi sa che vi sono al bucato da
teri garr qualche altro
e quindi al bando 70 ha portato una
rivoluzione è la stessa cosa era la
rivoluzione del nome perché gridava al
ghetto limitata dalla società americana
che in sulla roma per altri che con quel
colore con ribattezzarsi gridava io
esisto
io vivo io sono qui ok la storia dei che
ticketing vela verso uno prettamente
perché arrivato oggetto punto kevin dunn
e inizia a fare il rap è inizia a
diventare abbastanza famoso inter fare
dei visti ok inizia a fare il tempo di
dischi di lana di più i dentisti e
inizia a girare e alla milza stadi
stretta quindi dalle deve cambiare città
e va in una città ancora più grande dice
un altro step perché lì inizia a vedere
che sotto al palco da 50 erano diventati
certo da 100 erano diventati 200 le
copie vendute erano sempre di più quindi
non iniziati rocca vivere che questa
cosa ea vivere anche eventi che arriva
un punto di svolta incredibile perché lo
chiama c televisione lo chiamano in
televisione e qui vai in televisione
proprio per fare freestyle proprio per
fare il break
ok ed alla città dal cui se n'è andato
dopo alber se ne deve andare perché ho
bisogno di una città ancora più grande
capite e quindi la sua vita cambia il
successo lo cambia ma mentre all'esterno
car che positivo in realtà dentro lo
distrugge perché dentro di te lo inizia
a pensare che sia arrivato il momento
si scopre che di riscuotere con la
musica di iniziare a raccogliere tutto
ciò che ha seminato e quando questo
succede un artista quando l'artista
inizia a pensare di dover guadagnare con
la propria arte
il governo nettizzare a tutti i costi
purtroppo succede qualcosa che dentro
gli si spegne quella fiamma quella
stessa fiamma che lo portava a
descrivere le ditte della sua più le
vite del ghetto e lo portavano a dare
voce al ghetto ok quindi teoricamente
praticamente la nostra storia potrebbe
finire qui perché nella fontana tante
storie che artisti che hanno lasciato la
propria città e poi si sono montati la
testa perché si sono dimenticati del
posto dove erano partiti che è però
l'universo non è così bastardo sempre
non è così indispettito e nella mente di
kevin hall viene un miracolo
poco prima di trasferirsi nell'ultima
cittadini stiamo parlando lui aveva
fatto richiesta per fare dei laboratori
di scrittura creativa cioè dei
lavoratori diretto all'interno e le
scuole dei carceri per portare proprio
la storia dell'hip hop quella di cui
stiamo parlando stasera nelle scuole nei
carceri questo progetto che hanno
accettato
lui accetta di farlo e inizia a
raccontare la storia di tipo nelle
scuole man mano che inizia a raccontare
la storia dell'hip hop e le scuole
continua a raccontare la storia delle
donne alle scuole si rende conto si
impegna dentro di lui
la voce della sua gente terzo posto
della sua strada
ok il punto di svolta definitivo abbiamo
lui va nei carceri con l'intento di
insegnare i detenuti anrel fare ok
seguite tutto questo passaggio un po
complicati lui doveva andare in carcere
ad insegnare di giudicarle pare perché
perché il nec serve proprio a questo a
incanalare tutte le energie negative in
qualcosa di costruttivo e creativo che
cosa gli succede però che questi ragazzi
vedenti lo riportano a quello che era il
momento iniziale in cui lui sei
innamorato del popolo riportano inclini
bloc party con dj pure lo riportano alle
scalinate della scuola dove stavano dove
lui faceva cristalli per intrattenere
gli amici perché perché nei punti basta
un foglio e una penna una storia da
raccontare
non servono le radio non sempre la
televisione non servono le
visualizzazioni e tempi non c'erano le
visualizzazioni anselmi è successo non
sempre i soldi a queste persone a chi fa
hip hop ai libri che sono coloro che
amano li può sempre poco serve
rappresentare il modo da cui sono venuti
a raccontare una storia
allora lì avviene il miracolo quella
fiamma che si aspetta all'interno della
crescita di kevin resuscita ritorna e
lui scrive quello che il suo colore
miglior disco della sua vita io che
nella sorte quel disco non venderà
quanto quelli precedenti
magari non arriverà altri 10 mila
persone arriverà a 7 mila persone
le persone ascolteranno le storie della
sua gente le storie per cui lui ha preso
ed è andato via dal ghetto quelle stesse
storie quella stessa cultura quella
stessa magia chiamate il po che l'hanno
presa dal ghetto non ha portato verso
qualcosa di positivo verso qualcosa di
digradante verso qualcosa di importante
ad esempio che non ha mai trovato delle
droghe sintetiche perché avere terrore
che trovando le droghe sintetiche lui
perdesse poterli quel giorno dopo si
impegnano in una sola cosa regione rive
non poter oppure iniziato a leggere
migliaia migliaia non ha esagerato
centinaia di libri perché perché aveva
bisogno di parole perché per fare il
freestyle quello che possiamo
perché avete sentito prima no c'è
bisogno di parole
quindi questa cultura salva la gente
perché io sono venuto qui anche di
queste cose e non argomento che sembra
non entrarci ma invece centra tantissimo
perchè perchè ultimamente però che
l'incontro a livello mediatico viene
proposto come qualcosa che ostenta la
ricchezza l'altra volta ho anche visto
in prima serata su proprio sulla rai due
personaggi di cui non faccio
come per incanto senso di rispetto nei
confronti del microfono che professavano
la la giusta rappresentazione che sia
giusto stand tale che sia giusto
sostentare la ricchezza che sia giusto
iniziare a fare arte per arricchirsi che
io trovo che questo sia completamente
sbagliato perché l'importo mi ha
insegnato proprio altro li può prende la
gente e le troiette verso qualcosa di
positivo verso qualcosa e diana ciò non
prende i figli di papà e li fa passare
per delinquenti per vendere più copie
perchè ha imparato proprio questo e per
i criminali carcere non parlano di droga
parlava un dispaccio parlavano di
positività raccontavano la loro storia
perché erano stanchi della merda che
avevano vissuto prima e quindi vi
proiettavano questo qualcosa di più
forte è più grande ok ora da lì sono
alla ducato guidato la chiusura della
storia di kevin per chi viene in
arrivato a un certo punto deciderà di
tornare nella sua città in quella che r
che nel frattempo è diventata una città
bellissima e abitanti diana renault non
se ne accorgono però a lele mora c'è una
valenza è uno spessore culturale davvero
incredibili rispetto a bertacchi prima
agisce anche prima trent'anni prima però
quelli che sarà la ragazza
e quando tutto era ora che ha recuperato
tutto l'amore per la sua terra e per la
sua gente ora che la sua terra la lana
riportato avere respirazione tornerà più
forte con uno zaino pieno di esperienza
con un sacco di contatti in più con un
sacco di palchi vissuti in più con un
salto di dischi per mettere tutto a
disposizione della propria città o
teoricamente dovrei dirvi quali sono le
tue bugie
giusto o non mi interessano
lei lo vuole saperne di cedere dallo
sbagliato
no no non mi portassi se sbagliare è se
il bayern vorrebbe sentire ritorno in b
c è qualcuno aveva già capire è che la
nostra storia non si svolge alla fine
degli anni settanta alla le ma si svolge
alla fine degli anni novanta al cosenza
qui dove siamo qui adesso un po più
distante da un po di chilometri
qui è il protagonista non è che è un
ragazzo che si chiamava mirko che si
chiama ancora pubblico arrivato a un
certo punto al cambiare sono minchiate
per poterli ridare un mondo io sono vivo
io esisto
io sono qui grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]